okay some of my best work I think what  do you guys think it's good but how  about we add more dinosaurs oh can i  really add more dinosaurs it's are you  aren't you an intern yes I am  oh go time we got to upload this trailer  yeah I've got this guy guys did it  suddenly just become honest here your  your phone yeah thank you  you could have just used the flashlight  now after you guys  you're gonna get out of here  I gotta go you gotta go you gotta go  let's go on three three two  it's UNIX system I know this at some  point you're gonna turn this back into  my phone right can I get Instagram Zack  get that trailer on a floppy disk  oh my god wait so it was a cat  that made the dinosaur sound and tore  apart the monitor something seems kind  of  you  you